nothing great should be easy I'm gonna
tweet that right like why should have
anything great be easy [ __ ] man honestly
like you know this is where the most of
the money I've made in my life has been
between the delta of my marketing talent
and the person's stake of their product
I'm playing the arbitrage of the grey
not of the black and white math this is
a two hundred fifteen million dollar
company as the offspring of me of the
human being the top of the funnel now
I'm both
you know I'm both meaning I could be the
frontman and I'm the CEO oh not just a
CEO I'm operational I'm in it but so are
you
[Music]
the process that we created is a very
common process education might be the
only industry where we don't listen to
the user the end user
everybody else is obsessed with the end
user you are obsessed with your clients
and how they experience it your problem
and I got I got real news for you man
people out here aren't listening to the
end user either really yeah man I said
in like that's what marketing is like
coca-cola sits in a room and they're
deciding and they have all this
information from the end user and
they're not using it to your point when
somebody listens to the end user and is
obsessed with the end user they become
Amazon but they're but you know I become
me when I'm just listening to the end
user but man listen education is got no
chance government's got no chance like
you know like every but in business
ideologically it's supposed to do better
unfortunately it's not how humans roll
empathy is a rare trait
it's a rare trait I think way too many
people doing good right now are scared
to show any part of what they need
because they're worried that people
gonna be cynical to them I needed to do
a lot of things before I started putting
out a lot of content and on my cost and
so I don't judge people getting to a
place so I think that's number one you
you're number one you're the engine and
then everything else is secondary
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me tell you one of my super macro
points of view of why we're dealing with
a lot of things that we're dealing with
corporately and socially we didn't pay
the piper in 2009 when we were supposed
to
I believe accountability and I believe
in those kind of things and so I this is
sneaker collaboration I did with k-swiss
clouds and dirt it's the framework of my
life my clouds are my why what am I
trying to do what's my aspirations the
silly ones like the chase of buying the
Jets or being the most inspirational
impactful entrepreneur of a generation
and the dirt is the reason I have
respect from the people that work for me
because I'm in my [ __ ]
I love the dirt I respect you know
people ask me a lot of times who do you
who inspires you or who inspired you and
they always want like the Steve Jobs and
[ __ ] horse should answer the person
inspires me is the emails I get from the
single parent who is holding down three
jobs and gets value out of my flipping
content and like is that like literally
emailing me from picking up something at
a curb at 12:30 in the morning because
they're gonna sell for $27 tomorrow on
Facebook and the marketplace and they're
thanking me for making that video
because the extra hundred bucks a month
is meaningful to their family like
that's real life the dirt is grossly
underestimated people want to leave the
dirt get out of it and I want to op
things are happening to me I'm trying to
go deeper in the [ __ ] dirt
[Music]
[Applause]
today
there is no situation that I'm not
prepared for emotionally and I keep
building leverage to be able to bring
more value to the other person than I
require of them that's it in life let
alone running my business
I come from the dirt you know I came
from zero I lived in a studio apartment
with nine family members we lived real
humble real long my entire college
friendship Network half of her welfare
like I come from a dirt place I value
that dirt and I think one of the
vulnerabilities of corporations is they
get back and company
countries you get back
[Music]
we thirty or forty thousand dollars
before someone says what are you what
are you doing sure thing well big dogs
here that's have any questions please
don't hesitate to email me thank you
hello guys how are you
[Applause]
[Music]
the way that your grandpappy blindly
believed in radio and television
I believe in Facebook for the top of the
funnel period and the story that's why
most of your probably here I got you
with top of the funnel branding I surely
didn't get you here on a [ __ ] radio
television or Direct Mail that's what's
so meta about this right like sometimes
people come in here and they're like no
I'm like why'd you pay ten thousand top
of the funnel branding provide value at
scale right TV companies in 1987 priced
commercials at midnight to 5:00 in the
morning not enough for what it was worth
people exploited that that's why I
worked got it
Facebook let me give an example being in
business since 1979 has one incredible
advantage of one incredible disadvantage
it's called being in business since 1979
so the disadvantage is you're holding on
to radio and television based on
whoever's older than you and the family
or you grew up in the propaganda of
believing it because it's what got us
there right right the the advantage is
you have a lot of satisfied customers
literally if I was your partner I'd be
like okay cool the next trip to New York
we go back home we call email or reach
out to the last 500 customers that were
pumped and we literally demographically
break them down I want to see a white
family I want to see an Asian family I
want to see a Latino family I want to
see an african-american family male a
female 80 years old 60 rows 40 year old
20 year old I break them all down I go
film them with my [ __ ] phone and be
like and go tell us did you like us I
like them I go back home I run the ad
and I run an Indian family against
Indian Americans like this is so
absurdly effective that's way better
than the [ __ ] 30-second commercial
you're running on [ __ ] remnant
inventory on [ __ ] cable when do we
get these pens we've had this day one
I don't think so we're seeing I've never
seen this pain
did we pay for it good
who better pardon these I need to see
the barter list when I produce content
I'm not looking for what's happening on
the back end of that content I know
admiration and awareness will happen and
what if you make that switch and know
what you actually want to happen will
happen listen life is and it's so
amazingly simply interesting like if you
give it like it's karma is the most
practical thing on earth do you know who
loses when the internet comes along
everybody in the middle so either you
understand that and adjust or you feel
the ramifications hello how are you
brother of course let's rock and roll
I'm just very solution oriented like
complaining and dwelling never leads to
anything I believe in it never does you
know you don't [ __ ] know what's going
on behind somebody's closed doors I've
not been able to get rid of that that is
my that's how I live my life I do not
show me you know Kate Spade looks super
pumped to me Anthony Bourdain was a
super rich white dude super famous rich
white dude you know so there's obvious
unfairness and then there's the scalable
hidden unfairness I just don't judge I'm
just not in the mood of judging so when
I talk about stop crying and hustling I
feel like anything somebody's
complaining about somebody else could
also complain about something and I
don't know why we have so much judgment
in the air that somebody has it better
or worse and I feel like there's a lot
of things one can control I'm a big
believer that if you don't like the game
you're playing leave it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rocking hello hello saboteur
so man Turin Trenton nice to meet you
Michael you're this my brother Dylan a
king okay Lisa such a pleasure
it's going super well yes Miami spoke to
you on the podcast yep you remember my
social media marketing yeah yeah first
of all I want to thank you so much for
letting us comments yes it's crazy it's
I envisioned this ever since we talked
about cats I seriously I'm serious man
we already wrote it yeah yeah bathroom
all the wallet we get it's awesome you
guys are here
I like admiration more than I like money
I don't want your money I want you guys
to think I'm the best you know what I
mean yeah and I don't mind you not
thinking I'm the best at first I want to
be cheered when the buzzer goes the
triple zero I don't mind being booed in
the first quarter everybody else wants
to be admired being up 41 to nothing at
halftime but they're gonna lose my
leverage comes from I want less of all
this money not really the money was a
scoring mechanism to being good at
entrepreneurship something I thought was
cool but then it transformed when I
realized Oh getting the most doesn't
mean like you could just raise capital
and take money off the board but your
company dies I want and then so it
transformed into something of an
ambition of having real long-term right
I'm guys you think I've got something
going on right now I'm telling you wait
- the economy collapses I'm gonna rise
like a [ __ ] Phoenix because everyone
else is gonna get smoked out tried and
true wins
next yep
when we know next let's do we did the
selfie
it's FIFO selfie though you did it with
Kwame so how you doing good good so okay
the rocking FIFA yeah my first game of
FIFA ever ever no I mean I played FIFA
94 but you guys weren't born yet yeah
that was the first one I played the
first people ever Sega Genesis I got to
put this on are we going live on Twitch
what's up twitch so I'm late my first
visit FIFA 2018 I'm playing my first
FIFA 2018 match here I'm pretty excited
about it you want to give a one-second
bio of who you're about how you and how
you got here and barter it out the
sneaker game I love people that figure
out go ahead
absolutely so Brady Ben's on switched to
Z's I got the Gary bo threes I bought 45
pairs we struck a deal to get a game on
my Twitter and his twitch and and make
this happen so here we are boys
this is the one that sty started on the
street $5 to Speers $1 that's what I did
I have a wooden pickle part in 2008 so
after not getting a job at Nike that's
kind of how I started I love you you
know you know you tweeted something
about a week ago you're saying cucumbers
are underrated on the rain that was just
a red it's no joke this is what happened
is that my twitten this now my Twitter
game is [ __ ] fresh I ate like four
cucumbers and like some of them like
these are delicious I'm like you know
what cucumbers are [ __ ] underrated
people thought I'd met the cucumber
emoji anyway honestly bro for me the
biggest thing about this is this is what
I want kids to think entrepreneurship is
this is what I care about everybody
wants to [ __ ] come up with the uber
of [ __ ] waffles I'm gonna build an
app and like I'm building next sneaker
[ __ ] marketplace and everybody's so
[ __ ] impractical like no one you know
and [ __ ] put your [ __ ] head down
for a decade and then look up but nobody
wants to do that yeah I [ __ ] with that
people laugh well that by the way that
to me is the most important part of the
story yeah
the reason these kids aren't doing
anything is because they're worried
about people's judgement they can't be
bothered selling pickles out of cart
they're too busy trying to get to the
Hamptons jump on a squad and put it on
Instagram then you can [ __ ] own a
house in the Hamptons you were executing
my god I executed to nobody nobody heard
a peep from me for 12 years I thought to
put my head down was in a liquor store
every [ __ ] day didn't have a word to
say to nobody
everybody's trying to come out
everybody's trying to come out the gate
and say I'm an entrepreneur I'm like
cool I'm a basketball player do you make
money entrepreneur yeah
like literally people go print 10
t-shirts with some word and decide
that's their supreme
right and they're like y'all I'm an
entrepreneur I'm like cool I'm an actor
like you know like do you get paid are
you winning story story online world
scarce life bro big garyvee pickles for
life eat them eat them five fellas have
a good night
nothing great should be easy
you